welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and black panther wakanda forever just
gave us a new look at namor's tribal
clothing thanks to Empire magazine and
my God does this fish look fresh it's
some fresh fish look at him dude is
about to emerge from the sea dripping
harder than your average scuba diver but
what can Neymar's MCU outfit potentially
tell us about his power set because if
this small look at what we got of Namor
in this first wakanda forever trailer is
any indication this amphibious adversary
ain't afraid of anything so let's see if
we can find out why my nerd babies
because I have a sneaking suspicion that
Namor might just be an avatar of a god
much like Moon Knight is with konchu but
first do not forget to hit up
newrockstarsmerch.com today to pick up
our newest latest Obsession shirts
inspired by She-Hulk and House of the
Dragon they're not gonna last forever
people so please head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com if you want to
support the channel and look good while
doing it alright so I have a feeling
that name or the Submariner will have a
strong link to dragons in the MCU and
this very Ling will inform how his
powers will work and function in wakanda
Forever specifically his phenomenal
strength which has allowed him to go
toe-to-toe with the likes of the thing
of the Fantastic Four as well as hulks
like Red Hulk and She-Hulk as well as
his highly perplexing ability to fly
named Morgan fly I don't know if you
knew that and this seems pretty
abundantly apparent to me from his
apparel and something that I have been
suspecting ever since we got that first
look at Namor concept art slightly
before the first wakanda forever trailer
dropped because this gold green and red
blue headdress that Neymar wears on his
head very much resembles that of a
dragon type creature a feathered serpent
deity that I believe to have strong
links to Aztec mythology as well as the
great protector from shung chi in the
MCU I'm talking about the MCU adaptation
of The Feathered Serpent God known as
quetzalcoat that I believe is
represented by this wall art of a dragon
that Neymar touches in the first wakanda
forever trailer according to Aztec
mythology quetzalcoat was the revered
protector god of the wind and the rain
to the ancient Aztecs whose name
literally means means feathered serpent
which is very convenient and this God
has been said to have been around for
multiple cycles of life on Earth as
Aztec mythology believes that the Earth
has been destroyed and reborn a number
of times due to the actions and
sacrifices of the Gods but though he was
a God that appeared as a serpent a lot
of the time quetzalcoat did have a human
form as well a form that we just got our
first look at in the MCU really quickly
in omnipotent City in Thor love and
thunder portrayed by actor Nico Cortes
the green-skinned quetzalcoat can be
seen listening to Zeus in a feathered
headdress with the same gold green blue
and red color scheme as Neymar colors
commonly associated with his serpent
form and I think that this will be
extremely significant to Neymar's Powers
because like in the comics it appears
that Namor will likely have the ability
to fly though we have not seen it yet in
any of the publicly available wakanda
forever footage we do know that Neymar
will likely have his signature Wings on
his ankles as we saw in that concept art
wings that have been closely associated
with the character's ability to take
flight and I believe that these Wings
will be the gifts from ketoko himself
the Aztec god of the wind to Namor his
Avatar giving Neymar the ability to
glide on air currents like a dragon and
much like konshu gifted Mark and Steven
with increased durability and strength
and Moon Knight I believe so will Kessel
coat do with name more superpowered
strength and durability like Neymar is
one of the most powerful people in the
Marvel Comics Earth and I think this is
the MCU reason as to why like I believe
that in the MCU quetzal coat will be
revealed as the very same race of flying
sea serpent present in the mystical land
of talo as seen in the Xiang Chi movie
with a similar protective affinity for
the human beings that worship them and
if this is the case I would be willing
to bet that we are going to see comic
book namor's ability to do hydrokinesis
manifest itself at some point in wakanda
forever because if you remember from
chongqi one of the great protectors
primary methods of battle was through
the use of water bending hydrogen and
comic book Namor has used water bending
in the past to part the sea like Moses
as well as flood a prison cell of his
enemies with toilet water which is a
pretty shitty way to go get it because
toilets have poop in them but the reason
why I believe the MCU atlanteans will
have a strong linked with Aztec culture
is because of how Atlantis came to be in
the Marvel Comics as the sinking of the
kingdom of Atlantis was directly caused
by the celestials angrily triggering a
catastrophic genocidal earthquake and
flooding known as the great cataclysm
that happened around 18 000 BCE in the
comics now if we consider that Aztec
mythology believes that Earth was
destroyed and reborn four times in the
past and that the celestial sinking of
Atlantis is pivotal to their origins of
the comics I am willing to bet that
quetzel coat was worshiped as a God in
Atlantis before it sank and very much
influenced their culture to make it
appear much like the Aztec culture did
thousands or even millions of years
before the Aztecs even existed when the
earth reformed with life after the
cataclysm this might serve to explain
why there are temples that look somewhat
similar to Aztec temples when we see s
in the Searcher destroy the suspiciously
Earth-like planet in the first Guardians
movie during the collector's
presentation this could very well be the
sinking of Atlantis and the destruction
of all life on Earth as part of the
celestial plan however we also know that
the vibranium meteor that hit Earth
millions of years ago in the mcu's past
could have also been the culprit of this
great cataclysm in the MCU and behind
the sinking of Atlantis as a deep impact
such as that could have potentially
devastated the Earth as it was at the
time which would be a great reason for
Neymar and his people to not care much
for the thriving nation of wakanda that
sits on the very rock that caused his
people to go under the sea but
regardless of how MCU Atlanta sank we do
know that some atlanteans survive and
adapt to their underwater condition and
I'm thinking that quetzalcoats the god
of the Wind and Rain took pity on those
atlanteans who worshiped him and gave
them the ability to thrive underwater
and not die birthing the blue-skinned
Atlantean branch of humanity but the
this all being said I sincerely believe
that Neymar will be presented as a sea
serpent dragon Avatar in the MCU imbued
with the powers of quetzalcoas and the
great protector as they likely come from
the same race of dragon you know much
like the Black Panther is imbued with
the powers of bass the panther God and
Moon Knight is with konchu's powers but
only time will tell thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at masterton on Twitter if you
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and
really fun theories but more importantly
you can follow new rockstars wherever we
are on social media do not forget to hit
up new rockstarsmerch.com so you can get
our newest latest Obsession shirts that
are not gonna last forever but yes thank
you guys so much for spending time with
me and I will see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
thank you